[Music]  republican senate candidate adam laxalt  slamming democratic senator catherine  cortez masto over her support of  president biden's agenda during a news  conference laxalt who is seeking the  republican nomination to run against her  next year said cortes masto is partly to  blame for nevada ranking worst for  employment that's even though the  senator voted to infuse money in order  to keep local businesses open  she stood with with governor sisilak who  in turn stood with gavin newsom  and they had some of the worst pandemic  policies in the country and what did it  result in it resulted in one and two of  the highest unemployment  so in a statement a spokesman for nevada  democratic victory tells us in part  laxalt is a right-wing extremist focused  only on pandering to trump and nevadans  will reject his job-killing agenda once  again